good morning Hank and good morning
nerdfighters I bet you have two
questions John first why is this being
recorded on your eyesight camera and -
why are your puff levels so high those
questions actually both have the same
answer which is that I've spent the last
hour and a half walking around downtown
Minneapolis desperately looking for a
place that sells the little cable that
takes the information from inside of my
camcorder and puts it inside of the
computer unfortunately for some reason
Minneapolis seems to think that someday
is holy so I have not been able to get
one this means that my proper Sunday
video will not come out until tomorrow
but in the meantime I have to tell you
guys something very important with Hank
stop watching this right now I mean it
dude which is that Hanks birthday is on
Tuesday this Tuesday I'm getting him
something that I think is pretty nice
but I wanted to let you guys know so
that you could have time to get him
something to like I don't know what you
want to get him maybe you want to do him
the honor of buying his CD link in the
sidebar maybe you want to bake him a
Hank cake or maybe you just want to use
the magic of YouTube to wish him a happy
birthday but anyway particularly since
my video is going to be late I wanted to
let you know that Hanks birthday is
indeed on Tuesday and you should indeed
like if you have time and the energy and
you love Hank as much as like Hank as
much as I do then you should get him
something my real video will be up
tomorrow sorry
you can vote on whether or not I should
be punished in comments but I swear I
looked really hard for a firewire cable
dftba